okay let's go to our next caller from
the 6:07 area code caller from 607
please enlighten us with your name where
you're calling from and what you want to
ask about today hello this is Caleb from
New York and I have a question about the
Senate GOP health care bill okay um do
you think it will pass by the end of the
year and what do you think of the Ted
Cruz Mike Lee amendment I don't know
about the Ted Cruz Mike Lee event what's
that um it's a proposal five those two
senators that private health insurance
companies may sell a insurance that
doesn't meet the Obamacare standards as
long as they have one insurance program
that allows them to meet the ACA
standards oh okay yeah I haven't I
haven't heard about that I'll look into
it I guess I don't let me comment on the
first part because I think that that's
the really important part there's every
indication that version 2 of the Senate
version of the American Health Care Act
is dead and we were talking earlier this
week Pat about how there's really only a
couple weeks before the August recess
but now Mitch McConnell plans to
eliminate the first two weeks of that
recited read that yeah I would wait
before I fully believe that they're
actually going to miss half of their
vacation I think that if it doesn't pass
before the August recess that they are
going to likely have to do something
drastically different I still do think
it's very possible that something will
be passed before the end of the year but
will it really in inspirit represent a
repeal and replacement of the Affordable
Care Act
I don't know I'm very skeptical and what
does that tell you that in August
they'll have to go back home to their
constituents and give these town hall
appearances where they have to explain
why they're going to vote for the
American Health Care Act and the idea
that they're not really willing to do
that and they know that it's not going
to be good for them really demonstrates
how horrible this bill is and the
problem caleb is that you know
Republicans have been promising that
they would repeal Obamacare and that the
replacement would
lower costs increase access and
increased quality of care you cannot do
that that is not doable by moving
Obamacare to the right because Obamacare
is already right-wing so I think that if
they pass something before the end of
the year which is not unlikely it is not
going to actually be a moving to the
right from Obamacare in any substantive
way okay thank you for taking my calls
all right thanks Caleb very much
appreciate it